ma première saint valentin je crois que
j'avais 15 ans
[Musique]
et c'était le parcours classique petits
films au cinéma et restaurant juste à
côté rien de transcendant
alors ma première saint valentin s'est
passé l'année dernière
c'était dans une villa et tout s'est
très très bien passé
[Musique]
alors je ne sais pas si c'est le plus
beau film et c'est un film qui m'a
beaucoup touché ce fut le film begin
parce que c'est un film deux shih
mois dirty dancing et je dirais avec
will smith hitch expert en séduction
celle notebook verviers aller le
regarder out of africa avec aubert et de
fort mais je redis
n'oublie jamais
que jamais
bush est fait et italique je sais pas
c'est un défi c'est un mot quand vêtu
jacky rose au dernier moment où ça
allait ce qui me fait espérer qu'un jour
ça m'arrivera
[Musique]
waouh question qu'ai-je fait déjà dessus
on reconnaît
[Musique]
surprenant
changer un trait de caractère j'ai
appris l'arabe
j'ai envie de dire que comme tous you
voler les beefs mer
oui oui oui je les fais vous coller de
jouer
je suis répond d'un billet d'avion
à la 2 jours
c'est une surprise
pour un anniversaire ou
le coup était tellement bien monté
qu'elle n'a rien vu venir et par une
bombe et il lui fait un bon gommage un
bon massage et après on a à dîner aux
chandelles
voilà
[Musique]
la bachata rossa de la ligue arabe qui
est une chanson sur laquelle mais on
peut s'aimer peut danser ont fait
chanter leurs idées peuvent faire
beaucoup de choses à exécution
[Musique]
flers chocolat
si nos champs dès dimanche un deuil
[Musique]
entre amis jeudi les deux têtes à têtes
ça dépend
orly de poubelles
ça dépend des jours mais on va dire pour
l'occasion de ce fut une soirée méconnu
contre co-organisé par
[Musique]
visite sauf que ça a un côté sexe
il faut que les accepte l'autre avec ses
défauts et ses qualités
[Musique]